[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a este resumen especial de
diario de copas el programa de france 24
en español en el que analizamos todo lo
concerniente a la final de la euro 2020
y tal ya después de mucho tiempo logró
alzarse con el título primero en un
partido emocionante donde la selección
de inglaterra se había puesto al frente
al minuto 12 por intermedio de look show
italia tras un intenso ataque empató las
acciones sobre el minuto 67 por
intermedio de leonardo bonucci así
transcurrieron todo el tiempo
reglamentario más el añadido y
finalmente italia se impuso a inglaterra
con marcador de 3 goles por 2 en los
penales para celebrar su segundo título
en este torneo
a pesar de la pandemia londres pidió una
verdadera fiesta del fútbol gracias a su
selección pero para conocer las primeras
reacciones tras la final vamos a
establecer un contacto con nuestra
corresponsal en reinounido luisa pulido
luisa era una final que ansiaban los
ingleses desde hace mucho tiempo desde
1966 no han podido ganar ganar un gran
torneo y estaban en su primera final de
la euro como es el ambiente actualmente
luego de conocerse el resultado
pues de mucha tristeza de lágrimas
porque como lo mencionaba desde hace
muchísimos años 55 años
inglaterra no estaba tan cerca de ganar
un campeonato como estos de hecho inició
ganando el partido como lo mencionas en
el minuto 2 hizo este primer gol que es
considerado el más rápido de la historia
de la eurocopa y eso les permitió a los
hinchas soñar con la posibilidad de
tener este torneo 2020 que se está
jugando este año por la pandemia y
también de euforia porque recordemos era
esta final esperada que tenían los
ingleses soñaban con la posibilidad de
obtener este resultado esta eurocopa se
ha dado en medio de una situación bien
compleja que ha traído ilusión para los
británicos para los ingleses en medio de
la crudeza y de la tragedia que ha sido
el kobe pero esta final por supuesto
todavía se mantiene como una fiesta
porque para muchos ingleses el fútbol
era una buena excusa para salir de
fiesta por supuesto y bajo esa
percepción de que el fútbol siempre es
motivo de fiesta luisa háblanos un poco
como han tomado los ingleses sobre todo
los más cercanos a este deporte
este resultado luego de esperar tanto
tiempo por alcanzar la final
pues ha sido un mix de emociones sobre
todo de frustración porque como lo has
dicho pues se llevaba esperando por una
final desde 1966 cuando inglaterra ganó
la copa del mundo pero también por la
posibilidad de tenerla tan cerca es
importante recordar que inglaterra
empezó ganando este partido y gran parte
de esos 90 minutos lo estuvo ganando así
que les permitió afianzar ese sueño
estar más cerca de él pero en este
momento se vive como un momento de
tranquilidad de orgullo de hecho algunas
personalidades del primer ministro boris
johnson y también el príncipe william
que es el patrón de la asociación de
fútbol inglesa han enviado mensajes a
través de twitter a los jugadores al
técnico gareth southgate diciéndoles que
pese a todo lo que sucedió a esta final
tan compleja
tanto nerviosismo esta noche deben
sentirse orgullosos sobre todo porque
este es un equipo joven algunos
futbolistas jugadores tienen entre 19 y
23 años así que acarician la posibilidad
de obtener un resultado positivo en los
próximos años hay mucho futuro hay
muchas esperanzas aún muchísimas gracias
a luisa por ofrecer los detalles de cómo
está el ambiente en londres luego de
haberse celebrado esta final recordemos
que hoy concluyó la euro 2020 un evento
inédito que se desarrolló en 11 ciudades
del continente europeo para celebrar el
60 aniversario de la uefa hasta aquí
diario de copas continúen con más de
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]